thank you
[Music]
have any of you guys either seen a
miracle on on uh 34th Street
Matilda no and no do you know who Mara
Wilson is yeah the little girl Matilda
three numbers so far remember her super
cute yeah what happened to her that's
her right here
for any child it's not that bad well
it's not that bad oh but it is bad but
just but it's bad yeah that's Matilda
right um yeah Matilda yeah Mara Wilson
she's 35 now whoa um an interesting uh
reason why I'm bringing her up is that
this ties into the rider strike and
everything that's happened Okay so
you would think a person with massive
movies like that kind of like Macaulay
Culkin like you have movies that will
sell forever because not only are they
holiday flicks but they're also like
classics there's also Miss Doubtfire
remember you just got into it right now
oh really he loves Matilda oh the new
Matilda the original one yeah right this
is whack yes
you um you would think like the Royal
you think the royalties from like movies
like that would be pretty substantial
and they used to be depending on your
contract I heard they took advantage of
like child stars yeah well no they're
actually because of the contracts back
then you would make a lot of money
royalties but while keeping those same
contracts and how times have changed and
most movies are streamed oh the trick
the trick is that Hollywood kept those
contracts and did not adjust to how
streaming works so now you're like it's
not playing on TV you're making almost
NADA
now she makes uh since like streaming
became a thing she makes so little that
she got dropped from sags health
insurance in which you need to make at
least 26k a year to hold holy so sad
yeah and she's like yeah I don't she
goes I know I don't act that much but
still like it should at least break that
you know what I mean yeah as it used to
yeah uh so one big thing about the of
the rider strike is that they did not
adjust for the current day climbing I
see these are consumed yeah
um the main thing being streaming and
then the other detail being uh they want
to raise the bottom uh earner so like in
the guild right you have the bottom
people that are
um that they make the minimum amount
they want to just raise that for them so
that they get an actual livable wage
it's not like their day rate whatever
yeah because a lot of people that have
been making
um that have been writing content for uh
or even being head writers for massive
shows are like literally in the red for
their own personal finances and they're
not making anything
um and then the shows are wildly
successful why did the SAG guys join
what happened there because I know in
supporters okay so it was originally the
writers and they could come they
couldn't come in with a conclusion and
well all the students were also going to
just wait them out because they knew
that the writers were just gonna like
lose money burn into the red and then
have to like accept a weaker deal
exactly one of the I guess the third
feature of the writer's Guild requests
in the details of the of the contract
that they're trying to like fight over
and this I think is the hardest one it's
the um limiting the use of AI yeah and
that's where they they don't want the
studios to eliminate their jobs by using
Ai and I think that one's the hardest
because technically they're still
allowed to use AI to write the [__]
they're turning in yeah but the studios
aren't allowed to use AI to replace them
it's happening that's hard man and
everything's getting automated it's like
McDonald's has a ton of check-in kiosks
it's hard to like it's hard to impose
that on the studio to be like you guys
can't use it so that one's a little iffy
but the other things are completely
understandable because it's like I want
to write the shitty script like it's not
fair like robots doing it for free you
know what Snoop Dogg was saying this
about the music industry too he was
talking about how like back in the day
you would have like somebody bought an
album and it cost as much this much
percentage was negotiated it'll go to
the bottle but nowadays you can get like
a billion streams on like a streaming
yeah but it's not like that artist has
like a million dollars in their pocket
from you because it didn't like where's
the [__] money and now labels can use
Ai and just keep producing more Snoop
Dogg tracks and Snoop Dogg gets paid
zero for them if they own the likeness
the character if they own the lyrics
they could just make remixes over and
over yeah I can't wait till Tupac come
back
yeah it's it's one of those things too
where um the some some uh Executives
from some Studios have actually said
straight up
um we're just gonna keep this thing
going until these writers lose their
homes or just that's some [__]
screwed [__] dude that's [__] crazy
they can afford it yeah they can afford
it and writers can't afford that they
will they will bleed out quick because
like writers don't get paid that much
like and the accessibility to jobs is
tough too it wasn't like Baba biker yeah
Bob iger's like it's use of like well
we're still barely recovering from covid
and stuff like we can't even afford all
that [__] usually when Industries
tighten up like that it's because they
are strapped and they're desperate it's
rarely rare like that when you're in a
point of abundance because then when you
have money to when there's money to go
around they're actually taking more
risks so on the top end
um if they're not threatened for
survival
they're green lighting a thousand
projects but even when digitally like
before covet and all that right like a
lot of jobs were going out of Hollywood
old media was struggling a lot of
mid-tier budget movies weren't getting
greenlit because the traditional way
wasn't working so I think like in
general Hollywood's been suffering then
covet happened lockdown happened no
shoots were going on they were producing
less and I'm like yeah sure it's still
billions of dollars right but now we're
talking like maybe last like a couple
billion rather than 100 billion you know
what I mean like I don't know what but
the money's still going somewhere so
like that the all those like the Matilda
movie right it was they're still getting
the same place but Matilda's not getting
the money exactly it's going to the
studio so there's oh yeah the plays
still happen it's just the money is
getting channeled somewhere else you're
saying like the streaming money like
Netflix or whatever they're licensing or
Spotify or whatever like home alone is
getting coming in Home Alone is getting
watched the same amount but Macaulay
Culkin's not getting paid right that's
the difference and that's what the
writers are fighting for they're like we
just want the fairness that we were
experiencing before this change and we
want this to be adjusted for the new
lifestyle of how things are consumed I'm
wondering if if it's dollar for dollar
the same though so for example like
let's say a TV station license your your
your home alone to play right and then
they get higher ad Revenue because like
like let's say more man because like
that's what I'm saying is I don't know
right so like if if you're if you're
streaming [__] and the contracts are way
lower then that means what's going to
the studio is way lower which means that
then maybe you're gonna make sense
rather than dollars on the stream so
like I don't really know the math behind
it but I do know like traditional route
like the way that they have it on print
Super Bowl commercials all that they pay
[__] tons of money
versus digital they don't I think
everything all across the board
people just make less money generally so
like except for the studios because I
think that's the biggest thing where
it's like yeah publicly traded companies
you can look at the balance sheet right
so if you're Matilda let's say you shoot
a Disney movie you keep getting less and
less money and the Disney share keeps
going up it's like where is the money
going it's like um and it's very like uh
direct it's like you can just look at
the numbers like uh
like like I look at a lot of smack her
stuff with commercials and anyone who's
a commercial actor will tell you that
you don't make as much nowadays so yeah
they used to get residual contracts yeah
even even when you do get reserved it's
just lesser and and like with uh when it
comes to streaming what they're asking
for is an adjustment of any kind but
they purposely leave the Antiquated
papers the same exact way because it
benefits them and that's the part that
they're like really fighting about and
then there are they making the same or
more because I think that's where the
catch is like if the studios are
prospering like a [__] and
they're just using covet as an excuse
then it's like yeah there's so much more
money that they made that they're not
sharing I mean yeah there is
um it's hard to say that it's dollar for
dollar because it probably isn't because
you know it's not like if people were
buying Matilda on DVD for like 17
each it's not the same as if you pay 17
for a Netflix subscription and you
didn't watch it at all yeah like it's
it's just on there as a option right but
you're not paying you know when you buy
them they're actually just as expensive
yeah when you buy them on like Amazon on
our iTunes it's still like 20 bucks or
30 bucks right all right but they do it
so as if it's like a physical thing but
it's not even physical yeah and then
there were no costs for them they didn't
have to print the DVD they didn't have
to put overheads like way less and you
can't resell
yeah there's a lot of like different
details that they they want to get
looked at but so far they've met up and
they've walked away with no agreement
wow and uh Riders are gonna get [__]
they are gonna get [__] yeah like like
Netflix right think of all the movies
and TV shows they put out I think the
model with the TV shows like Ozark
they'll put out a whole season it gets
watched in like three days probably yeah
and then you're just left with like all
right what's next and I think they just
keep cranking out all this stuff also
where's the money go now that sag is has
joined the strike
anything live that like a live show yeah
it's done wow so like theater no no no
like like Saturday Night Live oh
continue they can't just like keep going
or like James Corden he's out like
they're all just like stopping dude
everyone's [__] because those are
people that are writing to the week
they're like they're like I'm writing
for so this is the time to be on YouTube
yeah you're right there Friday show
Thursday show or whatever yeah which
which brings me to the question because
South Park's like that they ride on
Monday for like it works insane but
would they strike if they're the writers
and the actors of their own business
what do you mean South Park like they're
the writers in the their voices can they
not make any shows they're not the
animators well if they're in the guild
if you want it yeah so everyone stops
work together if you're in the guild
yeah
if you're not then I mean no one you're
in the union but you also own the studio
so that you pay yourself and then you
strike against yourself yeah how does
that work because you're not people that
get points right like like Tom Cruise is
in mission impossible as an actor but
he's also a producer yeah yeah so you're
almost you work for yourself so how does
that work I think I guess he's not the
studio yeah yeah because then Comedy
Central and whoever like Viacom or
whoever owns that then South Park they
just own the IP and the and they're
producing South Park but they're not the
studio I mean the only thing that it
really says I guess like when it comes
to cases like that I'm sure it's super
nuanced and very very unique to that
person yeah but overall like going
against what the union has said they're
doing will just just get you either it
says disciplinary actions which you
could be kicked out of the Union which
that's not good if you've got a bunch of
residuals coming your way that are now
blocked yeah because a lot of the big
Talent they are the studio now too I
think like Brad Pitt who has like Plan B
Productions or like Medea yeah like like
uh Tyler Perry Will Ferrell is like what
like Gary Sanchez or something so
they're almost like they set up their
own to be the business yeah but if
you're also actor and producer credit
then like is it Mark Wahlberg building
one in Vegas he's trying to build
Hollywood but he has his own production
company too but he's trying to build an
in the studio also he's trying to build
the industry also any of these Studios
that you're thinking of including South
Park or or even Mark Wahlberg's they
still have to partner with other
students like Universal or whatever
distribution there's gonna be like all
this like that's why you see like 10
intros when you watch a movie it's never
just like one Studio it's always in
conjunction with someone else so that
also is gonna be complicated to to
navigate that's interesting the crazy
thing is that uh
now that all these actors can't work
who can we get on JK news
like they could just come in oh baby
yeah it's YouTube it's not what he said
I don't think it violates sag it doesn't
for sure
if we were Union you guys would be
[__]
if we were Union if you guys were Union
we would JK wouldn't be existing
yeah well you guys could keep striking
I ain't gonna strike me and Bart will
still do the show
you guys have done that well we'll
strike with you guys be like Joel bar
pay better and I'll tell myself I will
try
I will try and then the company will
just shut down dude it is pretty crazy
to think that all these actors and
writers like they're all just not doing
anything I need these guys to get back
to work bro oh yeah also you know what
you know what they also said this means
that it's gonna be another Resurgence if
not like the Revival of reality TV
because it's non-scripted oh yeah that's
the pivot
the TLC is gonna be the best [__]
show channel in the whole world and then
you can't have a host
isn't the TLC have all those reality
shows like 90 Day Fiance yeah but you
talk about the boot band no but like all
those shows still have a host yeah yeah
Fear Factor had a bunch of people that
were non-union but you still had Joe
Rogan yeah America the Most Wanted guy
yeah and he talks about the crimes but
he still have that guy no but like 90
days fiance that would be good 95 gypsy
wedding okay [__] Killers dude all
those kind of shows this could be the
Renaissance Era of reality TV what's
that down syndrome love one
there's a Down syndrome loved one yeah
there is a love on a spectrum love on
the Spectrum bro Banger of a show
honestly they need to bring that show
back or that was autism huh yeah yeah
okay and then there's man there's gonna
be so many the fat one my my 7 000 pound
life yeah that one's really good
quarters Porter Storage Wars oh I love
Storage Wars do you try to guess how
much everything costs didn't someone
just get like a [__] crazy payout on
the most recent show we want to watch
baby we're going to want to see you rack
up the bridge gonna be some good stuff
coming out but also the saddest part of
why I bring up Mara Wilson is the fact
that people that you love that invested
their time in their Heyday that thought
they didn't need to work as hard now
have to work again
foreign